if something happens to Joe Biden and
maybe they're maybe you can think about
it in a bunch of different
conspiratorial ways they want him to be
in danger they want risk they want
injury they want him targeted they want
a cause for war it seems like a
sacrifice well every conflict that has
happened there that the United States
has supported Israel which just to be
clear I'm a huge supporter of Israel and
we should be helping the Israelis and we
should be helping the Jewish people but
we've never shown up with two strike
carrier groups mhm to my knowledge I
remember I think this puts them I think
this puts Israel at risk it's one thing
when you have the ongoing conflict
between Israel Gaza Palestine Etc we've
seen it going on and on with the uh with
the Gaza war in
2014 it was the Israeli operation
protective Edge we had a great concern I
remember being in The Newsroom that this
could escalate to the point where Iran
declares some kind of involvement or
provide supplies forcing the US to to
respond in kind but that did not happen